MARISA COULTER: There
are forces out there, Lyra...
that you can't begin
to understand.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
I know you won't believe me.
I am doing this for you.
SPEAKER:
I am gathering the greatest...
from every world...
to help me wage war.
Tell me who this war
is really against....
and what you want from us.
Try not to die.
♪ (EPIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
COULTER: Many times, I've
tried to save her from danger.
It's cost me everything.
What could be more dangerous
than you?
The truth.
LYRA SILVERTONGUE: When I
was asleep, Roger spoke to me.
ROGER PARSLOW: Lyra!
I can feel death in there.
(SCREECHES)
(SNARLING)
SPEAKER 2: The Authority...
they have a power...
far greater
than our comprehension.
WILL PARRY:
What if I can't come back?
We'll find you.
SPEAKER: They are
but one arm of the beast.
We cut off the head.
Then, the rest will crumble.
No turning back, I guess.
No turning back.
(SHRIEKS)
This is the final rebellion.
Well, I'll be damned.